[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
les cancers masculins existent bel et
bien et pourtant la prévention et la
sensibilisation peine parfois à être
valorisée en France l'association sérum
développe plusieurs actions autour des
cancers masculins et pour en parler avec
nous je suis aujourd'hui avec Olivier
Jérôme président de l'association sérum
bonjour or l'association sérum a été
créée en 2014 quelle est l'histoire
justement de cette association alors
sérum est né effectivement en 2014 sur
un constat simple en fait on a alors la
plupart des patients étaient soignés à
Gustavo aussi à l'origine donc le prix
l'un des premiers centres européens
enfin le premier centre européen de
contrôle cancer et en fait l'un des
professeurs professeurs physalisi
d'ailleurs qui est membre d'honneur
entre guillemets l'association avait
fait une réunion on sollicitant
différents patients avec qui avait eu
des bons contacts et donc nous a
présenté un petit peu tout ce qui se
faisait toutes les problématiques qu'il
y avait et un constat en discutant tous
ensemble sur le fait qu'il y avait rien
qui existait en France réellement sur
les conservasculaires à contrario ou des
femmes se sont beaucoup mobilisées sur
le cancer du sein en l'occurrence il y a
pas que celui-ci malheureusement chez
les femmes non plus mais voilà vraiment
se dire voilà il y a rien qui existe
essayons de faire quelque chose on
n'était pas du tout dans la société
c'était une grande aventure
effectivement qui commençait et de se
dire voilà on n'avait pas eu nous à
l'époque moi c'est la date de 2001 le
concepticule que j'ai eu mais pas eu
d'accompagnement à l'époque donc
peut-être un manque effectivement à
combler et s'apercevoir que comme les
hommes n'en parlaient pas il fallait
vraiment prendre un peu les choses en
main et les accompagner beaucoup plus
que eux ne peuvent le faire tout seul et
pourquoi ce nom sérum alors sérum c'est
la fin du cancer donc c'est er et le
début de l'homme hom alors c'est venu
effectivement par un adhérent qui on
avait essayé de voir un petit peu quel
nom vous pouvez le faire et donc sert
homme alors c'est sérum aussi un peu
sérum de guérison et ça s'écrit pas
pareil c'est aussi sérum donc une serre
qui entoure l'homme qui l'accompagne etc
donc il y a plein de petits mots qui
vont ensemble puis on s'est dit ouais
cancer voilà la fin du cancer le début
de l'homme sérum c'était pas mal c'est
né comme ça et votre objectif principal
c'est de
utiliser autour des différents cancers
par nos masculins quels sont les actions
justement de sensibilisation que vous
mettez en place tout au long de l'année
alors déjà on intervient régulièrement
dans les hôpitaux à certains moments
alors beaucoup plus facilement au mois
de novembre effectivement qui est le
mois où on met en visibilité les cancers
masculins c'est la conduite en tout cas
on intervient sur des stands pour faire
de la sensibilisation auprès des hommes
ça c'est l'une des cellules des tâches
on a à côté de ça un centre d'écoute qui
est là fait pour que les hommes puissent
nous appeler puisque ils n'osent pas
venir en parler directement donc
téléphone vous avez ça et l'autre chose
qui est venu au fur et à mesure aussi
donc on aide effectivement à faire
parler on aide les médecins qui ont
besoin des associations qui ont besoin
d'avoir aussi quelqu'un qui traverse la
même chose que le patient parce qu'ils
ont beau être médecin ils ont beau être
très bons dans ce qu'ils font ils
traversent pas la même chose et surtout
on leur souhaite pas donc ça c'est
l'accompagnement qu'on fait et à côté de
ça au fur et à mesure des années on a
décidé de faire des spots ou en tout cas
de la sensibilisation de mon travail
aussi sur des petites vidéos on
travaille
sur des choix de passionnés on a
travaillé sur des vraiment des spots de
sensibilisation sur des petites vidéos
explicatives sur des Webmission sur
certains sujets qui va permettre en fait
de pouvoir par différents moyens de
sensibiliser les hommes parce que si
l'homme ne sait pas alors qui a des
cancers qui existent il va pas il va pas
forcément y faire attention et les
hommes sont un peu moins un peu moins
présents enfin un problème avec la
médecine ou en tout cas avec avec tout
ce qui est maladies que n'ont pas les
femmes on se rendrait général et de de
août à de août 2023 janvier 2024 vous
allez présenter la pièce de théâtre
radical sur le cancer de la prostate à
Paris et en province alors que quel est
l'histoire justement de cette pièce de
théâtre et pourquoi la mettre en place
alors radicale c'est un c'est un patient
qui est venu nous voir qui a derrière
l'association qui a qui a fait une pièce
de théâtre sur son vécu en fait de
l'annonce jusqu'à l'opération de ce qui
s'est passé et qui l'a fait avec humour
et en fait nous on aime bien je pense
que voilà faire passer des messages
sérieux mais avec un petit peu d'humour
permettent de dramatiser les choses donc
là c'est l'histoire de c'est l'histoire
de d'un malade qui a eu qui apprend bah
qui tombe le ciel sur la tête avec
effectivement tout ce qui peut y avoir
au niveau d'une opération par rapport à
la prostate etc donc c'est vraiment un
bon moyen aussi de sensibiliser parce
que tout le monde n'a pas accès à des
vidéos ou Instagram ou aux réseaux
sociaux faut savoir que le cancer de la
prostate on touche des hommes plus âgés
donc le théâtre était aussi une bonne
méthode on l'a inauguré l'année dernière
en faisant un mois de représentation et
on a vu que ça marchait bien on était un
peu frustré parce que ça s'arrêtait et
là finalement on a remis les moyens pour
pouvoir la jouer beaucoup plus longtemps
et on espère dans beaucoup de villes de
France et le faire pendant longtemps
parce que il y a plein de professionnel
de santé qui sont venus qui ont trouvé
ça génial et qui nous encouragent à le
faire en plus donc on a vraiment l'aval
de tout le monde pour que ça avance et
vous avez mis également en place une web
émission sur sur le cancer de la
prostate quels sont les objectifs de
cette web émission donc là c'est pareil
c'était d'expliquer donc c'est présenté
par Brigitte Fanny Cohen qui est qui est
une journaliste en santé
qui qui est le but d'expliquer un petit
peu ce qu'il a cancer de la prostate de
façon simple avec des mots simples parce
que bah quand les médecins s'expriment
des fois c'est les mots sont pas
toujours simple donc ils le font et on
accompagne effectivement ça donc une
première et ouais émission qui est sorti
et qui va parler d'une généralité sur le
cancer de la prostate alors ça s'appelle
c'est grave Docteur entre point
d'interrogation bien entendu c'est pas
grave c'est juste qu'effectivement il
faut bien prendre à temps et ça se
soigne correctement et après il y aura
une deuxième une troisième émission qui
vont sortir tout au long de l'année sur
la partie sexualité puisque ça engendre
potentiellement des problèmes de
sexualité et pour un homme c'est pas
évident comme pour une femme d'ailleurs
visite ça et puis d'autres
problématiques aussi sur la troisième
émotion qui sera sur l'incontinence
parce que quand on opère de la prostate
il peut y avoir des risques
d'incontinence qui se soigne très bien
mais encore faut-il savoir où quoi
comment et aller voir les bonnes
personnes vous proposez également un
soutien et une aide aux hommes atteints
d'un cancer mais également aux proches
vous n'excluez donc pas les femmes dans
vos dans vos actions quelles sont ses
aides ces accompagnements que vous
proposez aux patients atteints masculin
et à leurs proches alors on excuse
surtout pas les femmes il y en a dans
notre incision que cela pourrait nous
aider qui sont bien souvent un pilier
dans le soutien aussi de tout ça donc on
a aujourd'hui
donc notre centre d'écoute où on apporte
vraiment c'est à dire que bien souvent
ce sont les épouses qui nous appellent
bien régulièrement à la place de son
mari qui n'ose pas poser des questions
ou des fois du père de l'oncle du frère
etc donc souvent une femme qui appelle
qui prend un peu par la main comme une
nouvelle dans les hôpitaux donc on a on
apporte surtout l'expertise le vécu on
va dire ça c'est important encore une
fois les médecins apportent eux la façon
de soigner toute la partie médicale et
nous on apporte vraiment le soutien
psychologique de certaines façons on
n'est pas psychologue mais donc voilà on
a eu des formations aussi pour
accompagner les gens et de pouvoir
surtout que les gens se rendent compte
qu'ils sont pas tout seul parce qu'en
fait bien souvent quand il y a ce genre
de maladie ont tendance à se refermer
sur eux-mêmes un pas trop en parler
problème potentiel autour de ce que de
ce qu'est un homme etc de remise en
question ne vous en parle pas trop
d'avoir des gens qui en face on parle de
façon ça fait entre guillemets des
complexé qu'on pourra orienter donner
des conseils etc c'est vraiment une
grosse aide qu'on peut la rapporter et
c'est ce qui pour nous marche le mieux
vraiment dans ce qu'on fait pourtant il
faut expliquer que en cachant et on se
renfermant un petit peu sur un problème
ça ne l'arrangera pas ça pourrait même
justement l'aggraver et on pourrait
avoir des choses qu'on regrette
finalement derrière moi clairement
j'aurais tendance à dire que faire
l'autruche c'est jamais très bon vaut
mieux effectivement venir en parler
rapidement et aller voir le médecin
j'aurais tendance à dire pas pour rien
mais dès qu'il y a quelque chose de
bizarre et sachant que le cancer de la
prostate il y a pas de réel on va dire
signe avant-courage d'un cancer de la
prostate donc c'est encore pire donc
hormis aller voir son médecin et faire
des prises de sang sur un taux de PSA où
tout le monde n'est pas toujours
d'accord mais en tout cas qui est un
indicateur permettant de voir si après
au niveau de la prostate permet de voir
comment ça évolue et s'il y a des choses
à surveiller ça c'est important et si on
parle de médecin on s'en aperçoit
aujourd'hui beaucoup trop tard avec des
formes beaucoup plus graves et que ce
soit beaucoup moins bien il y a une
réelle
urgence ou en tout cas une réelle
volonté de votre part de de briser ce
tabou autour de autour des cancers
masculins oui clairement aujourd'hui
alors j'avais discuté avec un
journaliste une fois et qui m'avait dit
mais finalement
le silence des hommes tu les hommes et
j'aurais tendance à dire je pense que ça
c'est vrai c'est à dire que les hommes
n'osent pas en parler donc comme on en
parle pas ils sont pas au courant et
finalement ils vivent leur vie jusqu'au
jour où il s'aperçoivent beaucoup trop
tard effectivement il y a quelque chose
donc oui il y a une vraie urgence à le
faire on n'est pas assez nombreux à en
parler donc on a un peu plus de
bénévoles dans l'association et on a
besoin d'aide d'ailleurs s'il y a des
gens qui ont envie de venir nous aider
il y a pas de problème mais vraiment
d'aller très vite puisque il y a quand
même 50 000 nouveaux cas par an de
cancer de la prostate avec quasiment
entre 8000 et 9000 décès par an donc un
homme meurt en France toutes les heures
d'un cancer de la prostate donc oui il y
a urgence à le faire et donc un homme
averti en vous deux et s'il averti peut
aller voir plus facilement son médecin
faire attention donc c'est important et
vous recherchez également des des des
dons on peut on peut vous faire des dons
à quoi servent justement précédent alors
les dons vous nous aider à plusieurs
choses la première effectivement c'est
de faire vivre pardon l'association on
va se déplacer dans différents hôpitaux
en France on va produire la pièce
radicale par exemple donc pouvoir
effectivement apporter toute la
production qui va bien etc donc la pièce
de théâtre dont on parlait on va
réaliser des spots de sensibilisation ça
coûte un peu d'argent même si beaucoup
de nous aide et qui a du bénévolat dans
les gens qui nous est dans les acteurs
qui nous ont aidés aussi mais voilà de
le faire et puis de sortir des brochures
des fascicules qui vont permettre de
pouvoir sensibiliser ça et puis dès
qu'on le peut reverser un petit peu de
sous pour la recherche aussi même s'il y
a d'autres associations qui existent qui
le font pas forcément dans les cancers
masculins mais dans la recherche en
général et je rappelle notamment que les
cancers de faire le cancer les cancers
masculins ne sont pas une question d'âge
typiquement les cancers donc du
testicule peuvent toucher les personnes
du de 15 à 35 ans donc la meilleure
chose à faire c'est de se dépister merci
beaucoup Olivier Jérôme d'avoir été avec
nous sur sensation on peut retrouver
plus d'informations sur le site sérum.fr
et pour revoir ou réécouter cette
émission rendez-vous sur notre site et
notre application radio sensation
[Musique]